olá
o que existe por trás das etiquetas das
nossas roupas
quantas vezes paramos para pensar a
respeito
não é isso o que nos motiva no momento
da compra é a cor a textura o acabamento
o conforto o preço principalmente
naquele preço daquela peça linda né
bom bonito e barato que causa
taquicardia meu deus do céu é preciso
dessa blusa aqui no meu guarda-roupa
será que paramos para pensar em algum
momento o que existe por trás da
secretaria da etiqueta da nossa peça e
temos conexão com tudo o que está por
trás das nossas roupas
paramos para pensar a respeito à nossa
roupa né tem conexão com a nossa
personalidade que é o resultado de
vários fatores entre eles genéticos
fisiológicos que tem conexão com a nossa
crença com os nossos costumes da nossa
religião
então aqui a nossa personalidade ela
reflete tudo isso então somos seres
únicos né ainda que vivamos num meio em
comum cada um interpreta é essa relação
essa interferência de forma diferente
tem conexão também com a nossa
biodiversidade esse é um assunto
extremamente delicado é que a gente tem
muito nós temos padrões
pré-estabelecidos o tempo todo pela
mídia é existem muitos tabus eu tenho é
eu fico muito feliz quando a gente eu
posso discutir um pouquinho quando eu
posso né dividir com vocês o meu ponto
de vista e de várias pessoas que também
pensam da mesma forma
se cada corpo tem uma composição
genética de cada corpo nettheim a sua
fisiologia
tecnicamente falando né esse corpo é
diferente do outro cada corpo é
diferente do outro atacou um desenho
diferente do outro
então como é que a gente pode acreditar
numa verdade que o corpo perfeito
o formato ampulheta ombro proporcional
aos quadris e definição de cintura e se
eu não tenho o ombro proporcional aos
quadris e definição de cintura
se todos se torce temos a composição
genética diferença também seremos
diferentes
exceto em alguns casos de gêmeos
idênticos ainda assim temos diferença
ainda assim alguns a personalidade
também diferencia então né então que são
diferenças maravilhosas graças a deus
somos diferentes graças a deus somos
únicos através da nossa personalidade e
através do nosso biotipo né então o
corpo perfeito é o meu é o seu eu dela
né
e se a beleza e qual que é a beleza do
meu corpo é como eu posso não é
trabalhar a minha autoestima me
representar através da minha
personalidade e do meu corpo
se a minha etiqueta da peça da minha
peça representa algo ela tem que
representar o que o meu corpo deve
vestir o que é bonito pro meu corpo o
que reflete a minha personalidade e um
outro assunto também é que causa
bastante desconforto e poucas pessoas né
param para pensar no momento da compra é
que a questão da responsabilidade social
e ética
essa foto nessa dessa mulher chorando é
uma parente de uma vítima eu não sei se
vocês é o viram né ou ler alguma coisa é
de um acidente é de um desabamento do
edifício hanna plaza em bangladesh em
2013 onde mais de 1200 pessoas morreram
soterradas
as fotos são terríveis né então
bangladesh só perde para a china em
produção têxtil e produção mão-de-obra
barata
esses trabalhadores a grande maioria das
mulheres e menores de idade ganhando
menos de dois dólares por dia uma
jornada de mais de 15 horas
essa foto representa uma realidade não é
só lá que acontece nós temos essa
realidade muito próxima aqui mesmo no
brasil
creio que vocês é uma hora ou outra na
mídia né a gente descobre que tem marca
x né com trabalho escravo
só mudam os rostos mas é é um
preocupante poucas vezes para
para pensar se a marta que estamos
vestindo né
nos representam a nossa roupa um
vocabulário
nós somos a comunicação verbal e não
verbal ou gestual ea roupa é uma forma
de comunicação não verbal diz muito
sobre nós
ela tem que ser a nossa segunda pele ela
tem comunicar a nossa personalidade ela
tem que vestir bem a nossa biotipo e ela
tem que contar das nossas crenças nessa
representa a minha personalidade os
nossos valores da nossa ética
todas as vezes que eu escolho né o que o
fecho o neo o olho pra esses tipos de
problemas
a indústria têxtil é o terceiro
indústria que mais mata no mundo a
indústria do vestuário
através de mutação genética devido ao
uso indevido de agrotóxicos epis
necessários através de mão de obra
escrava mão de obra infantil e grandes
marcas netinhos etiquetas nesse acidente
em bangladesh que provavelmente muitos
de nós tenhamos alguma peça dessa marca
que é superlegal ostentar é o status e
aí a mão de obra é baratinha enquanto
agente ostenta uma grife tecnicamente
falando super interessante então a
partir do momento que eu visto né
essa etiqueta eu estou contando que eu
estou de acordo com os valores dessa
marca
então eu um convite pra que a gente
pensa um pouco mais a respeito é é de
quem somos a respeito do que realmente
eu quero representar e nós temos se a
roupa um vocabulário nós temos diversas
formas de comunicação de massa nesse
painel por exemplo a gente tem vários
tipos de beleza
essa mulher com essa lata na cabeça a
primeira vez que houve essa foto eu
fiquei extasiada tanta beleza totalmente
fora dos padrões pré estabelecido
não é isso colorido à personalidade eu
consigo né definir uma série de
características e objetivos para ela
ah ah ah outra começou de estampas a
outra com o jogo com a uma peça vestindo
um biotipo que tecnicamente falando está
fora dos padrões um pouquinho acima do
peso como elegância absurda a outra com
uma peça totalmente mais longe do corpo
porque é a cor a textura o tecido cada
detalhe da escolha da nossa construção
visual conta algo sobre nós o rosa claro
tema com uma comunicação de proximidade
delicadeza o pink tem uma conotação de
força de criatividade cada um ter sido
um mulherengo ele tem a uma
expressividade uma proximidade um tecido
duro rígido estruturados como única
autoridade comunicação atividade então
que qual a imagem que eu quero projetar
então a cada detalhe da minha peça tem
que contar as características da minha
personalidade
por isso que temos pessoas totalmente
diferentes temos o lula rodrigues é 11
um consultor de moda masculina daquele
senhorzinho totalmente fora dos padrões
pré-estabelecidos é a cara dele
divertido uma pessoa totalmente
aproximandante ética é construído na
construção visual do hertha ali
representado e chique é ser sustentável
ea gente usa muito a palavra aqui no
brasil xique-xique eu acho a palavra
brega chique né porque todo mundo fala
que trabalha com moda é tão chique
ó meu deus moda não é isso moda
vestuário uma representação comunicação
todo mundo se veste né
mas na própria a gente tem uma
divulgação de moda e que a moda é é uma
coisa fútil distante outro dia a moça me
falou minha sogra adora moda eu pensei
mas ela não está no entanto usando um
produto né então modo gentil vestuário
né é uma indústria que sair pra vender e
o estilo é como eu me apresento através
da roupa
a gente tem um segmento tem crescido
muito no brasil que é uma forma de ser
sustentável na moda não é a única
porque quando a gente pensa em ser
sustentável na moda a gente pensa apenas
que é muito importante a questão do
impacto ambiental né algumas vezes na
questão do trabalho da mão de obra
escrava infantil contaminação dos rios
enfim mas poucas vezes a gente pensa
também que a reutilização de peças é um
é tem uma grande contribuição para a
proteção do meio ambiente inclusive
porque o aumento ciclo de vida de um
produto nós usamos de 25 a 30 por cento
que tem no nosso guarda roupa
o resto é dinheiro jogado fora né compra
por impulso e a gente já vê o guarda
roupa fala e não tem nada previsto hoje
até porque há roupas vezes ela ela a
pessoa precisa muita segurança né
tem que ser nova pra me trazer segurança
e não há absolutamente nada disso né
mas a forma como eu faço essa composição
é que é importante é que me traz essa
segurança é um segmento que tem crescido
muito no brasil
na verdade não só o brechó gente tem
garimpos de troca de roupas entre amigas
a gente tem né bazar de caridade enfim é
que o brechó
ele vem profissionalizando né segundo
dados números do do mercado tem crescido
muito no brasil e tem gerado milhares de
empregos diretos e indiretos né eo
garimpo no trecho é quase que o vício a
fazer tatuagem quando você começa não
pára mais né então é através de garimpos
de roupas de brechó a gente tem várias
peças aqui com as meninas por isso que
elas estão aqui que são peças de brechó
peças antigas misturada com peças atuais
né
mas o objetivo é chamar a atenção para a
proposta cada um dentro da sua
comunicação visual que traz
exclusividade uma peça garimpada não é
uma peça massificada né então eu consigo
comprar essa peça e ter um visual
exclusivo porque se eu sou o único ea
comunicação visual a minha fala tem que
ser única também né ela demorou e o
brechó também democratizar a moda porque
ela em poder às pessoas né ela ela deixa
acessível para grande população de
classes menos abastadas é peças de
marcas talvez exclusivos de mais que na
realidade no dia a dia não tem a ver com
o orçamento da pessoa e eu consigo peças
a meu deus do céu tem peças de marcas
que não fazem parte do orçamento e
através de garimpo tenho peças de grifes
que eu gosto muito
pagando né até 80% do néné menos do
valor da peça então ela democratizar a
moda
tá e e através de também com garimpo de
perto do poço personalizar né e roupas
usadas personalizar essa peça que é um
pouco mais do que customizar acho que
todo mundo já ouviu falar aqui do termo
de customizar a personalização eu não
vou apenas mudar a gola da camisa ou
trocar esse bolsa os botões mas eu vou
entender que aquele botão tem a ver é
uma pessoa divertida então aquele botão
tem uma comunicação divertida uma pessoa
forte aquele botão que eu escolhi tem
uma uma comunicação de força e tem a ver
com o perfil da pessoa não só reformar a
peça transformar uma macau cem saia
é mas é colocar características naquela
peça que tem a ver com a personalidade
da pessoa e valorize o que é feito à mão
e chique né eo artesanato local
a gente gosta tudo que ela de fora né a
grama do vizinho é muito mais
interessante que a nossa então valorize
o que é feito o seu o seu é alfaiate
local a sua costureira local se têm
algum artesanato local que também está
contando a minha escola minha história
estou inserida nessa comunidade
tá então olha né no local e construir
uma identidade única
e aqui no brasil a gente tem ainda
alguns tabus em relação a compras no
shopping brasil um país me
exclusivamente religioso então a gente
encontra principalmente em cidades do
interior
alguns tabus ainda que que não faz esse
mercado crescer tanto deslanchar mas né
a médio longo prazo creio que isso vai
acabar não é muito é uma ligação de
roupas de brechó e roupas de segunda mão
de energia de outra pessoa então adquiri
lá eu trago aquela energia ruim pra mim
né então não compra roupas de brechó que
a roupa de gente morta né gente tem uma
ligação muito ruim com a morte de perda
de algo então não vou usar roupa de
gente morta estão roupas ou também que
pode transmitir doenças não sei de quem
era de repente eu posso ter contaminado
são roupas de pessoas ainda e se acha
que é o maior né pra pobrinho passar de
caridade idade não têm condições de
comprar roupa nova então usa roupas de
brechó e se eu comprar né eu estou
dizendo para a comunidade que meu e à
condição financeira não é tão legal
assim infelizmente é uma realidade
a enorme no brasil e diante dessa
construção criatividade é essencial
todos somos criativos né então convido a
todos a explorar o que tem no guarda
roupa bem que com cores com texturas e
estampas experimente né não é pra todo
mundo ficar estampados mas a cabeça não
parecendo um pavão se isso representar
por que não também né
porque né ficar presa padrões mas da
mesma numa personalidade mas é certa não
é mais certinha mais simétrica mais
contida
dá para trás quando a trocar essa camisa
dá pra misturar esse terno com outra
peça dá pra se comunicar de forma mais
descontraída é possível né a gente tem
que se comunicar o tempo
nós não podemos ficar presa padrões pré
estabelecidos
existe a questão da adequação também
alguns ambientes né
principalmente em ambientes corporativos
enfim tem adequação do uniforme a
adequação para aquele ambiente mas
sempre que possível vamos aproveitar a
oportunidade né
liberte-se é o mais importante de tudo
isso não é a peça em si é por mais que
seja uma peça barato peça manhã e de
tendência totalmente pacificada é a
construção como eu construa sua
identidade como eu construí o meu
vocabulário na representação do meu look
lembre-se é essa é uma frase que o que é
muito significativo para mim sofisticada
ter uma aparência construída através de
design sustentável criativo e único
tendo como preocupação principal
além da estética porque a gente fica
muito focado na estética né e pouco nos
valores que a gente falou lá atrás
o respeito pelo ciclo de renovação da
natureza a proteção da mesma e do
próprio homem tá essa etiqueta que que
está contido em minha roupa né tem que
trazer essas essa sofisticação dessa
consciência e aqui eu coloquei uma caixa
de texto pink porque é uma cor que eu
acho que ele representa muito se eu
estou falando em representação de todos
os padrões né
é que eu acho que é uma mágica criativa
trabalho com moda trabalho com
criatividade desenvolvimento de produto
então desde pequena quando eu penso em
algo pra criar alguma cor pink na minha
cabeça brincou não gosta de rosinha
rosinha delicada hoje pinto que a forte
né então fiz questão de colocar a caixa
de texto pink e também a foto dessa
senhora que eu creio que várias pessoas
conhecem chama íris é y é uma design de
interiores americana e ela não tem nada
a ver com moda mas ela é um ícone de
moda não é incrível isso ela eu vi uma
entrevista dela que uma uma famosa
editora de moda tatua a imagem dela no
brasil ela quase caiu da cadeira de
tanto rir
meu deus mas eu só me visto da forma
como eu acredito como eu gosto que o
visto não tem absolutamente nada a ver
com padrões ou com tendência eu vim
porque eu acho bonito que eu gosto
misturar isso com aquilo é muito
criativo obviamente que é design então
também trabalha com a criatividade
a autenticidade ela é o ícone de moda né
e que me inspira muito de uma frase eu
queria deixar para vocês que também é
muito significativa e que eu gostaria
que também fosse muito significativo pra
vocês né
conecte no mundo da moda ética e
sustentável investindo seu estilo é
quase que um banco a gente ainda vê em
pleno século 21 pessoas que se sentem
fez com a autoestima comprometida é
bullying é que acreditam numa verdade em
tirol zona numa indústria que está aqui
pra vender
então a gente tem revistas até dez peças
chaves que tem que ter no inverno né é
aí joga tudo fora do inverno isso no
verão creio que várias pessoas já leram
histórias ainda assim no século 21 é tem
que ter o tópico europa de tem que ter
tem que ter se você não tem não tem
nenhum corpo assalto próprio e as
pessoas sentem fez amargas e se trabalha
é a mexe muito com a autoestima é
assustador é cruel é cruel
a gente tem que cada vez mais né é é a e
no contra fluxo no contra fluxo e não
aceitar esses padrões pré-estabelecidos
né e uma provocação que eu queria deixar
para vocês tá
afinal qual a etiqueta que veste vocês
já pararam para pensar a respeito
vão parar pra pensar a respeito obrigado
a todos